you talk about performance without a
purpose what's that
so like for instance let's say you have
no races let's say you have no classes
no nothing you have there's no purpose
in your life you know people need to
have purpose to get up they need purpose
to perform
you need to get to a point in your life
where there's nothing on the docket
there is no 5K there's no
there's no I'm going to get into school
to be this or that and still perform to
the highest level
because what people don't get is one day
that thing's gonna come up
and if you're not constantly performing
without purpose you're not going to be
ready when the time comes
it's this magical thing purpose that
we're all looking for
but what's funny about it all is that we
need these things to perform
but we don't take a second to realize
the purpose is always there
the purpose never leaves us
because the very purpose is you
you are always the purpose there may be
another purpose like being a seal or
going to college or whatever but the
main purpose in life is you so if you
wake up in the morning and you don't
want to do something
you don't care enough about yourself
and that's what you need to really
research is man why am I not doing this
for myself because that is that is the
number one purpose in life
is to better oneself
so that's the only purpose I [__]
need so the reason I give up every day
even though there's no race or there's
no school there's nothing in front of me
is because I have pride in myself
but where do you go to you wake up on a
morning it's cold it's wet it's dark
you've got no cartilage in your knee
you've got shitty shots whatever it is
that's the issue today keep talking
you've got these problems right I need
you to keep talking about what you were
just saying it's warm on the couch your
message says stay stay in bed it's comfy
it's cozy you've got work later on you
had an argument last night you're
slightly hungover because I know every
[__]
ain't gonna do what I'm gonna do
so this is how you level up
that's how you level up I know there's a
whole bunch of people with that right
there that fires me up
that makes me [__] happy what you
just said that brings joy to my life
right there why because I know there's
so many people that have the ability
and just refuse to get off that couch
refuse to study a few more hours refuse
to go deeper to go further
and that's where I gained the advantage
it's so easy to be great nowadays my
friend because most people are weak
most people don't want to go to that
extra mile most people don't want to
find that extra because it sucks it's
miserable it's lonely you talk about
that you were kind of you know Lonely by
yourself
I was the same way
And That Used To Hurt Me growing up now
I [__] thrive in that [__] that's the
only place to be well that was one of
the things that
is so surprising about
growing up through difficulty you know
so loneliness is one example right
drawing up as a lonely kid
what you realize is a lot of the things
that you
feared or hated or embarrassed about as
a child
end up being the Genesis of the things
that you're most proud about as an adult
so the fact that you can work and thrive
in solitude gives you the opportunity to
be able to move to America and start a
podcast or decide to do uh hell week
three times in a row or it doesn't
matter how long or dark the courses
you're just gonna stay
the fact that you were uh forced to be
vigilant and to assess people to work
out what's going on
when you became an adult allows you to
detect the vibe and the energy of
whoever it is that you're speaking with
and know that this person's someone that
I want to hang with and this person
somebody that I don't right all of the
things in fact I would go as far as to
say there's not one thing in my life
that I see as a pure advantage that
doesn't have a dark side to it that came
about at some other point as well right
so one of the reasons that I spent so
much time as a kid in my bedroom
listening to audio tapes because I
didn't have anyone to play with right
only child a little bit sort of
unpopular so I'd be in my bedroom
listening to audio tapes we go to the
library every two weeks and we take the
tapes back and we get new tapes and I
bring them and listen to them again
right but you roll the clock forward 20
years and what's the 2023 version of an
audio tape it's a podcast broadcast
a lot of the things that you love and
value in yourself
in adulthood are the light side of
something that you were ashamed fearful
disgusted by when you were younger yeah
I mean I think that comes from
overcoming
a lot of people you know wonder how did
you become this how do you become so
vulnerable how do you how are you doing
a podcast now and you were this kid
you overcame things
you fought them
and now this is what happens this is on
the other side of overcoming
it becomes you become very very powerful
when you overcome yourself
all those things you once covered from
you're afraid of when you face him eye
to eye every day you know I become
a person who has a great podcast
let's say that someone listening who
resonates with what you're talking about
you know they've been through trauma
they've been through hard times but they
keep breaking promises to themselves and
they're struggling to get off the couch
and they're having a pity party
how can they stop feeling sorry for
themselves
that's a difficult one
because you have to want it
you have to want to be better
and it starts off with you have to have
pride in yourself
you you have to have pride in yourself
you have to have there's something about
you whether it's your last name whether
it's
just the smallest thing
you have to be proud of yourself if you
have no prior to yourself I can't give
it to you because you're always going to
compromise you're always going to fold
always I'm very proud of myself that's
why when people said
you know where you can do better than
can't hurt me
Roger that we'll [__] see it's that
Pride that wakes you up now that's about
bad Pride
I I'm a the attention to detail for the
human being I want to do I call this
thing like I want to be the standard
I want to be that guy like
every place I went in the military there
was this ethos
about how this place is how we're going
to live how we're going to represent
ourselves and I walked around and I saw
that most people didn't live up to that
ethos
like if you go to
whatever whatever company they they had
this mission statement on how we want to
run our company
I made one for myself
on how I want to be
and that is why if people can make up a
mission statement in ethos in which they
want to live by
and every morning you wake up you hold
yourself accountable to that mission not
a company is your own
make up your own mission statement what
do you want to be in life and once you
do that now you can work with somebody
to get better you can work with yourself
to get better but until you know what
you want to stand for
you will always just be sitting down
you'll never stand for anything what's
that quote if you don't stand for uh
something you'll fall for everything
that's it it's a true statement
in the book you talk about uh Roger that
there being two types of Roger that I
absolutely adore the second type
uh received orders given expect results
that's it so cool above and beyond more
than was expected that's right to the
ladder that's Roger that that is for me
what Roger that means received orders
given yep expect results expect results
that's right so [__] dope that is it
that is it and when you hear that from
somebody who gets it you know it because
you can look in their eyes
you feel that energy man it connects
immediately they're out here to get a
job done Roger that this episode is
brought to you by element element is a
tasty electrolyte drink mix with
everything that you need and nothing
that you don't I've replaced my morning
coffee with element every day for over
three years now and I've never looked
back it means I've optimized my
hydration my brain feels better I'm not
getting mental fog and it's helping me
to curb Cravings if I'm fasting
throughout the day even video guy Dean
uses it my favorite flavor is the orange
that in a cold glass of water upon
waking feels really really good it's a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium which
helps me to fill up my absolute best all
day also they have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy so you can buy it
and try it for an unlimited amount of
time and if you do not like it they'll
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it head
to drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Goggins then press here for the full
episode in all of its glory and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]